julie lava tchèque la rondo
astrophysicienne vous êtes une grande
spécialiste du trou noir pour vous
aujourd'hui la cie la journée
professionnelle la plus belle de votre
vie absolument ça a été incroyable de
voir cette image
la première image un trou noir
supermassif ça fait des années et des
années que des et easy mais le voir pour
la première fois c'était incroyable bon
alors là vous allez vous approcher avec
moi de l'écran ça c'est la formule
fameuse photo qui est extraordinaire
parce qu'on n'avait jamais vu ça si ça
c'est ce qui tourne autour cd en fait
les éléments de matières qui vont être
tirés cela s'est pas peut-il à 40
milliards de kilomètres de diamètre
donc c'est pas comme une planète c'était
un petit univers en soi là absolument
c'est énorme mais ce qui est important
de se rappeler ce que ce trou noir ici
qui se trouve au centre est extrêmement
massif on parle de 6 milliards de fois
la masse du soleil
donc il est très très compressé si je
prenais par exemple la terre et que je
le compresser à la même densité que ce
trou noir la terre on devrait la
compression à peu près de la taille de 1
cm c'est ça quel point cette rumeur sont
dangereux là beaucoup de matière si on
pouvait être là oui l'on aspire tout ce
tournoi sont peut être là y'a quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur c'est
une très bonne question
donc le point important c'est que si on
se trouve vraiment proche du trou noir
oui on va sentir sa gravité oui on va
espérer être aspiré dedans une fois
qu'on franchi cette barrière qui
s'appelle l'horizon on peut plus en
sortir même si on avait la fusée
spatiale a plus puissante on pourrait
juste plus en sortir même la lumière
peut pas s'échapper ya plus de temps il
n'y a plus rien là et c'est ça que la
théorie ce qui est intéressant ce
qu'elle nous dit c'est qu'on centre du
trou noir il y à toute la masse qui est
compressé en une singularité
ça on le comprend pas encore nos lois de
la physique fonctionne pas à ce niveau
là comment est ce que la masse peut être
compressés dans un tout petit point
infiniment danse ça c'est une question
roi et le trou noir là pourrait en
principe avaler notre système solaire
3,4 fois là il est très grand donc la
distance qu'on voyait c'était à peu près
quelques fois la taille du site
m solaire donc très grand et si on se
trouvait très très proche de ce trou
noir oui le trou noir pourrait
complètement absorbé le système solaire
mais un besoin se trouve très loin de
nuit alors le trou noir
puis il ya encore des mystères on vous
comprend qu'on traque tout ce qui passe
autour
ces gigantesques on pourrait voir une
expo the big bang
c'est une très bonne question parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de l'analogique on
peut faire entre un trou noir qui a
tendance à écraser pour l'instant les
seuls indices qu'on en sait que le trou
noir va attirer et une fois que la
matière rentrer dans le trou noir
c'est fini un peu plus échappé mais
beaucoup d'analogies on se trouve c'est
une très bonne question pour l'instant
tout ce que nos équations nous disent
c'est que tout est compressé dans un
tout petit point
infiniment danse infiniment petit
exactement qu'est ce qui se passait ce
niveau là ce que ça va dans le dos
dimension on le sait pas d'autres monde
peut être potentiellement oui comment
einstein avait pu prévoir l'existence
des tournois sans jamais les voir parce
qu'on les voit pour la première fois
aujourd'hui comment il a pu arriver
théoriquement avec la certitude de
l'existence des trous noirs
historiquement c'est vraiment fascinant
parce que einstein en 1915 il avait
publié sa relaté général pour la
première fois et ses équations prédisait
clairement du moins mathématiquement que
les trous noirs devaient exister mais
c'est tellement intrants étrange le
principe d'une singularité que même
einstein il trouvé ça trop étrangers
faisaient le trou noir pour pas exister
pour vrai c'est juste des concepts
mathématiques donc aujourd'hui d'avoir
la preuve concrète que oui ces trous
noirs existent surtout les trous noirs
supermassifs a été vraiment une
découverte incroyable et ça nous amène
ou en terminant sa lose sanou gens vers
où la science va aller là maintenant
qu'on les a vues qu'on l'a 9 juin c'est
vraiment une nouvelle ère en astronomie
dans le sens que maintenant on peut voir
les objets qu'on ne devrait pas pouvoir
voir notre sens on va apprendre beaucoup
sur la relativité générale les trous
noirs sont les test ultime de la
relativité
on va prendre d'autres photos de trou
noir on va voir est-ce qu'ils sont
pareils ce que ça varie d'un trou noir à
l'autre on va avoir de plus en plus des
meilleures images
ça va devenir de moins en moins flou
donc beaucoup d'avancées qui vont
arriver bientôt
c'est très difficile pour nous de
concevoir tout chat mais même pour des
grands scientifiques comme vous un
moment donné voulu dire limite ça
devient même difficile pour vous de
concevoir cette réalité là oui
absolument c'est il faut toujours penser
en astronomie c'est grand c'est
différent c'est dur de comprendre la vie
de tous les jours pour les trous noirs
il faut comprendre la relativité ce qui
est quelque chose qu'on n'observe pas
tous les jours pour nous là et les lois
de la physique sont très différentes ici
sur terre mais c'est justement ces
photos là qui nous permettent de prendre
a reculé de dire ces choses là
existaient vraiment incroyable donc pour
nous pourquoi ça existe qu'est ce que ça
change le ça existe les trous noirs dans
dans l'univers je dirais que maintenant
ce qui est vraiment clair c'est que non
seulement il existe mais qu'il ya des
versions super massifs donc vraiment des
millions des milliards de fois la masse
du soleil
ce qui est important de savoir c'est que
oui ces objets sont très compacts mais
il ya tellement d'énergie a tellement
gravité qu'un trou noir techniquement
peuvent détruire une galaxie entière
ça c'est entre autres ma spécialité
c'est d'essayer de comprendre qu'est-ce
qu'un trou noir fait exactement sur son
environnement s qui détruit un galaxy
alors que ce qu'il fait il fait beaucoup
de choses qui changent complètement les
propriétés des galaxies et pourquoi il
existe c'est une très bonne raison
pourquoi il existe on est en train
d'étudier on essaie de trouver les
premiers trous noirs pour essayer de
comprendre comment les premiers trous
noirs se forme
parce que c'est comme ça vu le big bang
au début et la fin d'une histoire c'est
le trou noir
ça c'est là une belle analogie à faire
pour l'instant tout ce qu'on sait c'est
que il faut être très proche un trou
noir pour être absorbée par un trou noir
donc on a aucun danger pour l'instant
que tout l'univers soit absorbée par les
trous noirs mais peut-être un jour on va
comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
julie lavoie tchèque la rondo merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé je suis sûr
que les gens sont comme moi la maison
sont fascinés par cette découverte en
fait cette réalisation technique
cette prouesse technique normand le
disait d'un reportage pour pouvoir
photographier ça il a fallu 10
des parts autour de la terre des
télescopes super puissant et qu'on vous
mette ensemble toute cette puissance de
calcul alors qui sait jusqu'où on ira
merci beaucoup merci ça fait plaisir